[Music]
all right it's finally here this is this
is the Apple Vision Pro this this is the
beginning of Apple's spatial Computing
Journey their first headset AR VR
wearable face computer whatever you want
to call it and this is the unboxing so
everything that I show you guys in this
box it's going to be a representation of
what you would get should you decide to
spend the
$3500 that it takes to get one of these
or in this case actually $33,900 because
this is the 1 tbte Vision Pro you'll see
the accessories you'll see it booted up
for the first time and this is very much
the beginning of our uh Apple Vision Pro
investigation and series of videos so
definitely get subscribed to make sure
you're among the first to see that when
the rest of those come out so big box
but the headset is relatively small
shout out to Jerry everything for the
knife and uh
inside this is a really soft box
whoa and this here is a third little
box so this is an incredibly flimsy box
but I'll just take this one out so the
three things we have now are the Vision
Pro headset in this box The Vision Pro
Zeiss lenses so these are Optical
inserts so if you have a prescription
then these come in the box and they will
magnetically attach to the headset so if
you wear glasses you can still use the
headset and this is the optional $200
extra vision Pro travel case this thing
this is a whole aesthetic I'll get to
that in a second I'm just going to leave
that right
here but this is the headset itself it's
going to slide
yep out of
this there we go so this is like the
size of I mean it's bigger than a Mac
Box this might be bigger than the Mac
Studio box
but
there you go and it's got all the pull
tabs I do expect pretty good uh
packaging here this is such a high
pressure first gen product for Apple so
I'm expecting pretty good packaging for
this introduction to a first gen thing
take the tabs
[Music]
off then it's like like a shoe
box
okay so there's the headset so the
headset comes with this little cover on
it and it's dressed up with one of these
bands this band right here is the one
that you see in all the commercials it's
this really soft stretchy fabric
material and it's in this sort of
cardboard head this is the solo knit
band there's another band though that
I'm pretty sure comes with this that is
called the Dual Loop band so so put this
the side real quick and see what else
comes in this like shoe box size box so
this pops
off this quality and then we're in to
the inside which is a design by Apple in
California pamphlet oh I bet there's
stickers in here oh there's a microfiber
too okay then there is the light seal
cushion oh I think you get two of these
yeah there's one thin light seal and one
thick light seal I'll get to that in a
second and at the top there's a lot of
explaining to do some more heavy Vision
Pro
paperwork and this is the Dual Loop band
so this is the second band that goes
both around the back of your head and
over the top of your head we'll try that
out for Comfort over the solo knit band
and then there's your power so the
battery that comes with The Vision Pro
is this thing right here it's all very
white everything in this box is either
white or silver it's pretty
heavy so
this smells pretty new it's got this uh
White braided cable and I don't know if
Apple's even called this mag safe but at
the end of this cable is one proprietary
connector right there
and
that connector is what plugs into the
side of the headset and this is the
battery the 2 and 1/2 to 3H hour battery
that comes with Vision Pro it says on
the back actually
3,166 Mah
hours I know a lot of phones that have
5,000 Mah batteries that feel much
lighter than this so I'm curious why
this feels so heavy but that's the
battery and then in order to get more
than 2 and 1 half hours or to charge the
battery you have the cable USBC and the
wall brick so let's see what the wall
brick says I hope it charges
fast 30 WTS so not super fast but this
is a 30 watt brick USB type-c and then a
ctoc braided cable okay that's it for
the inside of this box so now let's go
over these accessories so okay let's do
the paperwork first this is probably the
most common stuff everyone's going to
get this this is a little booklet of
what's in the box and a sort of a first
and that is all the uh pairing it to
your iPhone putting it on for the first
time connecting the straps I'll show you
guys this oh and
even how to store the cable around the
battery so apparently you do not want to
wrap it vertically but you do want to
wrap it horizontally with a little bit
of
slack okay I bet there's I bet there's
stickers so polishing cloth and that is
a different polishing cloth to the one
that comes with their monitors oh it's
nice and thin that's a nice that's a
nice polishing cloth people are
comparing it to the like $20 polishing
cloth for the studio display and the pro
display this is a different polishing
cloth the front of it is glass you're
probably going to want to use this to
wipe it down once in a while so I feel
like this is a microfiber I'll keep I
know some people unboxing this who are
going to be very disappointed in the
lack of Vision Pro themed stickers all
right so when you buy an Apple Vision
Pro everyone actually has to go through
a sort of a face scanning process you
actually use the iPhone with the face ID
sensors to measure the depth and scan
around your eyes and your face and you
end up with a custom fitted light seal
the light seal cushion is either thin or
thick so maybe you have the optical
inserts and you want it a little further
from your face or you just want a little
extra cushion this would be the thicker
cushion that you would
use okay so there you go that's the
thicker cushion
but the idea is the light seal around
Vision Pro is shaped to roughly match
your face it's not like exactly custom
molded it's more that they have a preset
number of different sizes and shapes and
when you do the scan it picks the one
that matches you the best to give you
the best immersion let's take the
plastic or the cardboard off of Vision
Pro and
uh huh sort of a standard head size I
guess right there and if we take this
protective off the first time dang
there's your glass lot of lights in this
room so it's going to be pretty
reflective but now you can probably
imagine why people are going to carry
this Vision Pro cloth notice it says
Vision Pro on the microfiber hopefully
you can see that but yeah so when you
get the headset you're going to notice
two things one this is the thicker
version this thinner version pops off
and two this light seal this is the
custom light seal that pops off and then
you're just left with this this is the
Entire Computer for Apple Vision Pro
it's pretty small it's not unlike a lot
of other VR headsets but it's got this
aluminum housing around the outside you
can see the tons of sensors and glass
and it is very front weighted this light
seal is what's ideally
shaped to match your face and block the
light out it attaches just like um
airpods Max's you've seen airpods Max
headphone covers just like that there
you go and I'm going to go with the thin
light seal
cushion and there's the the normal look
to the Vision Pro headset now let's take
uh the Dual Loop band out because this
is the other one that there's been a lot
of talk about the weight of the Vision
Pro and this is the reason why Apple has
decided to include two bands in the Box
there are different band sizes as well
so when you measure your head you're
either getting a small medium or large
size for your bands so I've got mediums
of both of these for this dual Loop
let's take it out so you can see so much
cardboard uh there's two Loops one over
your head and one behind your head so
there's a very specific process to
taking off and attaching these bands
with Vision Pro so I'm going to put this
on for the first time with out booting
it up just so you can see how this works
so this is the solo band right
here kind of goes around the back of
your head and then if I'm in the right
yep this spot right here this you just
crank
this and it tightens it up yeah and the
weight is really basically just now
pulling it onto the front of your face
all the weight is on the front and it
kind of lands on your cheeks and on your
forehead this is how it looks in all the
commercials it's the most simple looking
band you can pull the band up or down to
kind of adjust the way it sits on your
head but as you can probably already
tell that might get a little
uncomfortable so to take this band off
and switch to the other one all you got
to do is you see this uh this orange
pull tab in here this orange pull tab is
just to release the band from The Vision
Pro so if I pull that it unclicks the
metal and I pull that other one and it
just pops right
off and that's the uh headset without
the band attached to it and you have
these little little pods here over each
ear which are a bunch of speaker drivers
pointing down into your ear these are
some seriously small components they're
so dense though like this is heavy
despite being small so if you want to
put the other band on it's basically
exactly as you'd expect
attaches like that and like that and now
you can uh change it with velcro you can
make it taller in the top taller in the
back so let's try it let's try taller in
the
top and taller in the back well that's
so much more well distributed and I
happen to adjust it pretty close to my
head pretty much
perfectly that is going to be much
easier to wear for longer but of course
now you have this
thing across the top of your head so not
everybody's going to like that but I
think it's immediately a better fit it's
more comfortable wow okay I'm probably
going to be using that more often but
let's get to this uh this travel case so
this I guess isn't really a travel case
as much as it's just like a protective
outer layer for the glass since this
whole outside which has a ton of
fingerprints already is just covered in
glass you might want to just pop it in
here and then theoretically
maybe put that in a backpack I don't
know if you would want to but this is
this is the external extra Vision Pro
travel case it's got this handle on the
top but and it extends out a little bit
that's
nice that's well thought nice and tight
and
then it opens up and it's got sort of
molding in the places that you'd put the
headset so this is where the the battery
will go and it's even got this molded uh
spot for the cable so I can slide that
in there velcro it down and the cable
should be able to just wrap in here then
the other
side
another
case and then it says this is where your
oh accessory pouch so this is where you
put polishing cloth power brick and USBC
charging cable these
things
makes sense keep them in there activated
carbon deodorizer do not
eat then you put the headset in
here put the accessories in there and
close it up that's actually pretty solid
I know people were making fun of the
price of the
$200 uh Vision Pro accessory case but
the thing is I wouldn't want to travel
with this without the case and I do
think people are going to want to travel
with this the number one use case I've
been looking forward to with Vision Pro
is uh
airplanes so I'm going to need a pretty
big backpack to have extra room for all
of this but I do think I'm going to be
trying that let's uh let's boot it up
for the first time let's get it all set
up so this is what you'll have to do
when you get out Vision Pro ready open
the
case get your battery out first the
battery has a special cable on the end
get your headset out maybe take off your
knit cap or whatever this is called pick
between your thick or thin light seel
cover I'll go thin pick between your
dual Loop or your solo knit band I'll go
solo knit and then if you want to charge
it up or plug it straight into the wall
the battery doesn't appear to have a
removable cable I'm sure some Apple
store has some tool to remove this cable
whenever they need to replace it but
what it does have is a USBC port on the
side so if I ever want to just plug the
headset straight into the wall I'm
plugging the battery straight into the
wall but assuming it's charged the last
step here is to go to the left side of
the headset and you see this little
proprietary circular thing right here
all I'm going to do is line up the dot
with the bottom and then twist and it'll
start to Glow just like that and that
means it's starting up for the first
time takes about a minute to boot up and
then
I'll go right into the setup process
which I'm sure you'll all want to see on
camera
[Music]
ah and I see a check
box how do I
look ridiculous do I look great or
ridiculous decent okay I can see you
guys so there's a little hello script
and it's booting up for the first time
but I'm going to save this all this
setup and all of this using Vision Pro
that's going to be the next video so
last thing I'm going to show you is the
Zeiss lenses if you happen to wear
glasses or have a prescription you will
be able to use this headset as well with
that prescription with a $100 pair of
Zeiss lenses I think it's 100 bucks for
readers and 150 for prescription lenses
but either way they're really quite
small and they're magnetic and since
Zeiss runs a world of glass this is kind
of your only option is these things
right here all you got to do though to
attach them is take this
off and you grab one of the prescription
lenses and you
just snap it in place like that hope you
can see
that it's a pretty strong magnet I do
not have a prescription but what I've
been told is that then you go ahead and
scan this code with the headset so that
it knows what your prescription is and
adjusts everything accordingly which I
think is pretty well thought out but I
think that's where I have to end it so
stay tuned definitely get subscribed for
the following videos cuz you already
know I got to set this thing up I got to
show you guys how to use Vision Pro show
you guys what I've been talking about as
far as weight distribution the games you
can play the experiences you can have
the movies you can watch the apps that
it has there's a lot more so get
subscribed to see that and big shout out
to the sponsor of this video ankor so if
you're even considering getting a Vision
Pro you probably already have an iPhone
in which case it would be good to at
least know about anker's new mag go
lineup so they've got some charging
accessories this one I think is pretty
sweet this is three in one so it's
called the wireless charging station it
unfolds it's lightweight and Compact and
you can charge three things at once your
iPhone up on the mag safe charger then
something like airpods down here at the
cheat charger at the bottom and flip out
an Apple Watch charger and a 30-minute
charge can give your Apple Watch series
9 almost 50% battery but this one is
actually super convenient to me this is
the mag go power bank so again mag safe
slap start on the back of the phone but
it's got the screen on it so you can
always charge on the go and there's a
built-in battery and we love good
built-in battery but it's 10,000 Mah
hours so you can charge your iPhone 15
Pro almost two full times without even
plugging into the wall and there's also
a nice little stand so you can have it
in a what's that feature called standby
mode whenever you want just by popping
it up like that so I like that too so
both of these things can charge your
devices that up to 15 watts wirelessly
and they're good with G2 as well so they
can charge your non iones if you want
that so I think it's worth it check it
out Link in the description and shout
out to ankor again for sponsoring this
portion of the video so that's been it
thanks again for watching and I'm going
to go set up my Vision Pro now catch you
guys in the next one
peace w
w w